las protestas de este viernes en
paraguay por la gestión de la pandemia
dejaron contra las cuerdas al gobierno
de mario abdo benítez que ha pedido a
todos sus ministros que pongan a
disposición sus cargos el presidente
respeta a las manifestaciones pacíficas
y en ese sentido hoy ha convocado a su
gabinete están llegando los ministros el
presidente ha pedido a todos los
miembros del gabinete que pongan sus
cargos a disposición lo que queremos es
que toda la ciudadanía sepa entienda es
que el mensaje de la ciudadanía llegó al
presidente de la republica a evaluar las
situaciones de ayer de cada una de las
carteras las protestas sacudieron el
centro de asunción y se vieron
enfrentamientos entre manifestantes y
policías que generaron una veintena de
heridos y la condena generalizada de la
oposición por lo que consideraron una
brutal represión policial tras los
hechos el partido liberal y el
izquierdista frente guasu pidieron la
salida del presidente y del
vicepresidente a través de un juicio
político en el senado el presidente abdo
benítez y su vicepresidente hugo
velásquez deben irse la falta de
medicamentos en los hospitales públicos
y la lentitud en la llegada de
hicieron dimitir al ministro de salud
julio mazzoleni este viernes pero la
oposición responsabiliza a todo el
gobierno por la situación